welcome everybody
with a heavy heart
but with appreciation for the whole
journey
the last episode of family what
i'll stop it i'm just kidding
i did think it would be funny if i just
blindsided you
just to get your reaction
yeah you know
um well first of all today's episode
sponsored by feels hellofresh uh rocket
and upstart thank you
um
i think let's be honest okay
families was meant honestly as a gag
following up for enemies it was it was
and you know it turned into something
really fun and special that people
enjoyed i had a blast dad and i had a a
lot of fun
i had fun everybody had fun it was a
great time it was
but it was always meant to be a limited
run i'm the fact that we even got 10
solid episodes out of this i think is uh
is beautiful and i've got all my don
arcs the don arks are you have the
donuts are in the millions uh
you know i that i i talk to them all the
time on on that cameo thing that i write
back and forth and
uh
no it's been a blast the whole thing has
been a blast
there's actually more don arks than
actual butterflies at this
i don't i hope not no there's not many
of them according to you so i hope not
if you could cast a spell and turn all
the don arks into monarch butterflies
would you
well no they're people i don't want to
do that that's more important because i
was just you know pros and cons no no
yeah okay if you could wipe out okay if
you could kill 10 random people would
and but then you saved the monarch
butterflies forever would you i would
never kill somebody just random okay
okay let me adjust
are you asking me such a theoretical
question interesting ten people on death
row
no i could push the button no okay okay
one person on death row who's for sure
guilty of anus crimes and he's already
been executed by the state
you push one button end his life
and save the monarchy
oh god ethan i can't i can't answer that
question no i refuse the classic time
travel question ah hitler when he was a
baby i kill him
yeah but no question that's snappy yeah
okay i that i snapped his little baby
neck yeah
one motion yep yep okay
what is that one that one deal where
uh
there's a train going and you have the
option of pulling the lever
the trolley issue yep okay so that's
that's a tricky one the issue dan okay
so here let's put it this way
one inmate on death row guaranteed did
heinous crimes guaranteed did heinous
crimes he's going to be put to death
he's got a year left on death row he's
on one side on the other side every
monarch butterfly okay
you know
uh
you know theoretically
you know intellectually you say
there's no you know there's no contents
but when you're right there at the
moment
the the thought of killing a human being
you know oh yeah i oh my god all right
i'll save my butterflies he'll kill that
guy
if he's
turns out he was wrongfully convicted oh
my god
that never happens come on yeah that's
never happened
listen but you know like i was saying
i think that we should end while the
show is good there's a big part of me
that's like we should you know we could
keep this going forever
because it's so fun and nice but i think
we have to end while the show is good
like seinfeld exactly like seinfeld and
while the show is good
you know
hopefully we'll just go out with the
episode will be better than the oh yeah
the last episode was that was horrible
which was not i liked it
[Music]
to you
until we meet again
i'm not going i'm not i'm not for the
rest of me i am i am oh yeah no i'm
still your mother yeah i'll still see
you okay
you're just singing happy trails to me i
well i meant for the show right right
right i didn't i see your how do you
feel about the ending of the show
ah
you know i went into this not really
wanting to get involved and let mom do
it all and kind of be off camera but no
i've i've enjoyed all of it and um
you know the requests i've got on cameo
although i'm not
close to the number that the queen of
cameos that the number she's throwing up
there it's great and you know when you
feel close to the fans and uh it's i i
love you guys are good man you guys have
a knack you guys are entertaining i
loved it i i gotta be honest i'm gonna
miss it i mean on tuesdays it's like we
get to film and and uh i'm over
oh well you know every sunday
aside from the occasional
no i want you guys here all the time
that's we don't understand i'm like
please come over we need help
well i have
well we do things on saturdays and
sundays and you know aside from the
occasional humiliation that was forced
upon me oh
[Music]
well i know i know this was really the
whole plan behind all this was ethan's
attempt to get even with me and yeah
you're getting close
i was no not even close i was talking to
someone on you know on the cameo we were
writing back and forth and she was
asking about the dynamics with our
family and i was recalling remember when
we went to seminary with your cameo well
you know she's asking me questions and
so i'm kind of talking to her she's
turned it into a free yeah you just are
fatting i'm just like i'm having so much
fun yeah and and i was talking remember
when we went to yosemite
and what was that game that i kept on
flipping off like it was uh the game of
life remember
center dial it came flying off do you
remember that i remember the game of
life oh i do remember that i couldn't
turn that i was like
six times in a row there's like a little
push thing with dice in it right well
you turn it yeah
and it kept coming off like time after
we were just rolling on the floor
because she could not
walk
in memory yeah
and we we were playing chess every night
we should do that again we should do a
family trip like that what that was it
was so much fun definitely board game i
was telling her nice i was telling her
how we used to play risk
and you know dad always used to win
[ __ ]
no no once you turned a certain age you
totally stole the crown from dad i have
a lot you're real you're really good at
strategy i don't know who plays risk i
swear to god dan
dan
games i've played i'm undefeated at that
game yeah i'm just saying oh that's it
let's throw down a challenge we all have
to play at risk let's do it i think on
the air that would be great oh yeah oh
that's not working
all right well anyway
um well we used to if we could talk
about risk for a second when
okay go ahead this is your last show
just do whatever you want yeah
we were pretty hardcore risk players and
this is back in the days when they were
wooden pieces
that wasn't good enough we got little
h.o size army men
so we had army men and little cannons
and little infantry men instead of the
wooden pieces sorry that comes with the
risk board no they're plastic now this
was the summer of risk at the sweets
house the summer of risk yeah
all of our friends we'd get together and
play a whole summer of all kinds of
different things where we just went
crazy and did one activity generally
during the summer and those were the
good times that was the summer at risk
and it's all fun and games till someone
tips the board upside down on purpose
that's that that that's unforgivable to
actually do that it is
yeah
well at any rate um
you know this is it but but don't don't
fear my parents are going to be part of
the show from now on i'm thinking like
during
episodes with big dramas happening on
youtube
or in the world we can call my parents
up and get a drama summary oh yeah we're
good with that i i love it so i'm gonna
i'll make sure they have a segment going
forward still yeah
by the way what's your cameo total
compared to dad's
another humiliation attempt here by
ethan okay no in fairness you had
mentioned
from when we were on the air what's the
number
okay what's yours dad
i'm looking right now
i love the whole cameo dramas now you
know we talked about it on the last show
of the h3 pod and
poor a b didn't get a single one
and ian and zach each got like 50. and
poor a b didn't get a single one
well i'm at lucky thirteen
good
what is the difference between this the
cameos and the streak
what is that you do ask me that every
time i don't i don't understand that
have you rejected any
why would i reject well if they say oh
tell you you just ask you say something
like anti-semitic or something no
everybody's been
stellar i've really enjoyed talking to
the uh to your fans
well
uh
i i don't know
i can't help you with that well i've had
152.
bro
that is amazing i want to talk to
everybody
that's awesome
she's probably up on the leading uh
cameo
producers now cameo star you're right up
there with white claw gabe
actually they're next to each other on
the homepage i know that's kind of
embarrassing
why is that embarrassing
wait what is embarrassing about being
next to white claw gabe because doesn't
he just say
you know
the f word
baby it's from the mean what he does mom
am i allowed to say that word who's that
handsome guy next to rudy giuliani dad i
need to dude this picture you chose is
so horrible this could be why it's
mostly a picture of jessica as a baby
like whoa
i know i have a photo of you use your
phone it's a smartphone it's a
smartphone it has a camera on it just go
like that and you'll get way more
uh i think maybe people don't recognize
you in that picture nobody's gonna
remember yeah it's mostly a picture of a
little girl like what says gary klein
okay so here we are on top creators my
mom's number three she's actually two
spots ahead of your boy
white claw gabe [ __ ] yes baby
do you want to try the white claw gabe
well you know i don't
what
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] it's friday [ __ ] baby
[ __ ] yeah yeah very good it's good is
there school tomorrow
[ __ ] baby no
they're work tomorrow [ __ ] baby no
yeah baby friday yeah it's friday
see you guys so goofy
it's just so good you underestimate
gabe's power i guess so he's pretty
popular
well at any rate um
you wanted to give someone a shout out
before we get to i did you know i i was
you know now that i'm all involved in
this i i kind of look for things and and
uh
one of the uh two youtubers
i i'm gonna screw up his name like i do
everybody's
i don't know if it's rep
rep zion reptilian
there you go i think it's repsion
repsion anyways his dad's really sick
and and his best friend is really sick
so i just wanted to
send my best wishes and and a virtual
hug
my mom to him she's like caring about it
you're building parasocial relationships
with your these people you're watching
well you know they're sweet kids and i
you know it's really
it's a tough thing when you're you know
he's a guy and it's his dad oh
absolutely you know so our hearts go out
if only there was this kind of love on
youtube as a whole i think we'd all be
making uh
be a happier world
definitely yeah and all the creators mom
mentioned last week just were oh
did a little shout out right yeah
he started out his show calling him wet
noodles
so anyway before we get to the show i
want to give a shout out to ela climb is
there any ela climbers in the house
on thursday we're having just an amazing
collection coming out thursday at 10 a.m
um first of all the hoodie you guys saw
that you all loved that my mom was
wearing oh i love that hoodie
so nice and toasty coming out this
thursday that's a women's exclusive here
let me show you the one i'm talking
about
let me show the legend on instagram i
can hold this up
um this one here so this is coming out
wow what a beautiful model
yep she is
and then this one i don't know if you
can see it really good but this is the
nicest watercolor shirt i've never seen
a technique like this it's called
it's
it's brushed
watercolors it's really a nice
and they they actually do it by hand
with a brush and i've just i've never
seen this technique before it's so
beautiful
really looks great yeah and so and then
show off that one more okay and this
one's you want to stand up so they could
don't yeah donna stand up
stand up this is so cute so it's a got a
short little uh
you know well not too short but it's
it's short it's stitched on it's like uh
i can't i can't recall the name of the
technique patchwork yeah it's really
nice and it says don't touch me yeah
exactly
so that's coming out this thursday oh my
dad's got it and then this one my dad
was too big for his 2xl
my mom made him take it off oh he he
looked like he was wearing his dad
but it's a uh the lore yeah velour type
and it's like the box diamond
on the back embossed embossed beautiful
beautiful hand feels nice would be nice
and warm
with winter coming up thank you thank
you peace and love this thursday i like
the color thank you thank you okay today
your slang word is so let's move on to
the oh here i go i'm going to screw it
up i can't screw this up that's my left
yeah you better rack it up this is your
last chance to get paid
no no no facts i'll print
[Laughter]
that's funny close that is good
okay so today's word is touch
grass
touch grass it should be easy to
remember you know some of these things
do people actually use this absolutely
well let's see what it means we'll take
a grass
if you would say to someone go touch
some grass be down to earth be real
oh that's a good that's a good guess mom
do you have a guess
um
touch grass
is that kind of like for good luck touch
grass let some grass
yeah like before you go on stage touch
grass bro
it means like break a leg mrs mays
everything goes crazy the marvelous mrs
mayor oh everything went up well tits up
i know that saying but when you're
saying tits up like that no no no it i i
actually thought it meant to stand up
straight but it means it means
everything's gone well okay
yeah that's why i was confused your
usage was confusing me yeah touch grass
means
you need to go outside basically
and get back you need to you need to get
your your guess was pretty good it's
like you need to
you've been on the internet too long you
need to go touch some grass like that
unplug
exactly
which was also called normal life when i
was a kid yeah we used to touch back
when i was a touch grass when i was a
kid yeah even you
yeah i was famous for grass stains on my
knees by sliding and doing things you
were famous for that yes everyone knew
you as the grass
well grandma my mom certainly did at
least those are never gonna come out
yeah the only ground the only grass i
touch is in final fantasy 14.
[Laughter]
we don't know what that means but i'm
sure it's funny it is it's a video
okay you ready so touch grass touch
grass okay
all right so you know i wanted to do
some retrospective stuff here today but
before we do we have some top of the
show stuff dad for example
dad you gave me some horrible shaving
advice
do you acknowledge that you gave me bad
advice you said shave
against the grain
i did say that okay well this guy took
your advice uh oh and he's got
lacerations all along his neck
are you serious look here's a photo he
said i watched the new families
oh my god
do not recommend dad
i would suggest trying a new razor
instead of maybe one that's six months
old you think that's the problem i mean
a good sharp razor
should not dude if you go against the
grain it pulls the hair out of your neck
yeah
he's really cutting everything wait
you're still standing you're still
standing with against the grain that's
how i shave wow then look no scars
wow that i can see anyway you use an
electric razor
uh not for this area you really oh you
used a regular straight yeah it was
enough
but all right well
well uh
speaking for age three
uh you know when you are responsible
which i'm not claiming we are in case
you have an attorney
uh
good luck put some aloe on there it'll
be fine okay and shaving advice keep
doing the same thing just get a new
razor get an electric razor okay get an
electric razor
that poor guy
wow
cold-blooded and
gingers really that didn't apply to
gingers anyway so there's that you're
saying that people who have red hair
need to use different techniques exactly
[Laughter]
just saying that because he had red hair
of course but
it's always a good idea i mean obviously
the thicker your any other stereotypes
you want to throw out there
against marginalized groups you know
what i i've got some info about gingers
when you go under anesthetics yeah they
actually take more anesthetics than
someone who is brown hair or blonde hair
that's true
check it and that's the truth that's the
truth that is
yeah we gotta find no facts
that's the fact expression no facts oh
but it's but it's not
would it touch the grass okay uh
ucihealth.org whatever that is says uh
they need about genders need about 20
more anesthesia to be sedated
why did you know that
i don't know i i don't know i just know
that what does that mean i learned it
somewhere i need more anesthesia i don't
know that's a weird but i knew that how
about left-handed gingers do they have
the statistics for that
well anyway uh my dad made a really
interesting cameo that rolled upon our
desk
you know what you did
you made a cammy my dad made a cameo
that uh made it to the subreddit uh oh
what did you say here i'll read it to
you 50 is everything watch gary
celebrate my friend's love for team
skeet
did you know you messed up here wait do
you mean that everything that i'm
sharing with the people on cameo can
absolutely everybody else can read of
course we can and we are
well what is if they want it private
they can actually do that
okay thank you don't do that i'm in a
chat i want to watch everything well but
it's up to the buyer that there's an
option of whether or not no you guys got
to keep it public it's important for us
i mean i don't care but i'm just saying
for the for someone who i'm saying
50 is everything watch gary celebrate my
friend's love for team skeet these guys
need to be paying you you know it's team
skeet that paid you that made this cameo
request for you knowing that i would do
this
i don't do you know that for a fact no
no no
yeah i don't know hey it's their 50
bucks whatever they want to do
that's a good i know man well anyway
here's my dad
making a shout out now he's being paid
to be making shout outs to team skeet
what yep
you did a shout out to king keems teams
team ski yeah just out of the goodness
of my heart 50 bucks
what did you say raise the price for a
request for team ski shout outs yeah
yeah yeah okay here it is how are you
this is gary klein from the h3 families
podcast
father of ethan
husband of donna
your good friend tony
asked me to reach out to you
and uh
give you praise for your love of team
skeet he says praise for love my friend
ned loves team skeet can you please
celebrate him well
congratulations for your love of team
ski i'm sure they would be the first
ones to agree with me now not knowing
you two guys i don't know whether this
is a bit sarcastic a bit humorous but
whatever you make the request i'm gonna
fulfill it for you so
um
i guess my origins with team skeet went
back to my initial conversations trying
to defend myself well at any rate you
know
it wasn't embarrassing and it's just
funny i mean check in with team skeet
and you'll be able to get your own what
are you wearing look at your your shirt
it's like
a h3 hat and shirt thank you both that's
an old shirt it looks very comfortable
no i like that he's representing h3 you
know isn't there a commercial where the
guy goes with the dating thing and his
it's funny when when
the top comment this is so dense with
information it's tremendous value for 50
dollars
he's a canadian
oh my god
someone said you're already becoming a
clout demon be careful dad
a cloud
read the comments
it's funny when mom called me and to
help her
record one of her cameos i changed
shirts so my shirt look better now my
cami is i'm it looks like i slept in it
which i may well have but uh all right
let's get so here here we we've actually
got a lot planned for our final episode
here my mom put together you guys have
probably heard that there's a big recall
going on
in california yes
gavin newsom our governor is being
recalled
um
by
let me be honest i am not in favor of
this recall i am team gavin i'm not team
gavin let's not say that but like the
alternatives are due to dog poopoo
there's like antibacters and [ __ ] on
that i think someone with that name is
running actually
56 people i mean the alternatives are
literally
my mom's main focus is nothing she did
an analysis of all the top contenders
running for governor on how good they
are with the butterflies
towards the environment right no no
butterfly well butterflies equals
environment set the ocean on fire as
long as the butterfly flies survive
well no i don't want to set the ocean on
fire either
okay so we're doing that which we'll do
now and then we also took gave you guys
a narcissism test
did you guys take that i took it it
didn't that was kind of a weird test
the dark triad we'll talk about that
when it's pulled up because i have a few
comments okay so we all took that
previously at the dark triad
do that once before like way back didn't
we no
and we've got advice coming up we got a
retrospective we're gonna have a lot of
fun here so mom tell us who is good
for the butterflies go ahead gavin
newsom
you know
i i don't want to get political it
doesn't matter if you're republican or
you're a democrat
uh
or an independent yeah it doesn't matter
it has nothing to do with your choice of
what about a ginger
gingers are all good because i heard
they i heard it takes more anesthesia
they match the monarchs so they're all
good
so you know i i took the liberty of you
know me and my notes i i i wrote some
things down here and first of all the
sierra club opposes the recall okay so
that's number one that should give you a
little did they have any any specific
stance on the monarch butterflies well
no they don't have a stance particularly
they didn't shout out the monarch
butterflies but
the recall
would disrupt and halt progress on
policies that california need now
and a distraction from critical issues
facing the state like the pandemic and
climate change so there we go climate
change you know okay um and who is
behind this whole thing i mean that's
what you have to look for who did this
recall what follow the money follow the
money boom follow the butterfly the man
behind the curtain are the polluting
industries people yes indeed
give me the deep give me the dirty d
well you know let me just tell you that
um
the three top contenders well one of
them is is the one of them who who looks
like he has a really strong uh chance of
winning is what's his name his name is
larry elder he's he's like the the
top contender
and he's actually giving newson uh a run
for his money i think he has a good
chance
in this race
and um
you know he it
it's it's very strange he um
he doesn't he denies the existence of
systemic racism
which is really odd because the man is
black
so i don't understand that he's opposed
uh he opposes gun control of any kind he
thinks minimum wage should be abolished
i mean really
he doesn't believe in masks for teachers
he doesn't believe in masks
he doesn't believe in vaccinations he
doesn't believe in testing for they
believe in testing yeah yeah yeah but
what does he think about butterflies
he doesn't like him he doesn't like well
hold on what's his environmental policy
well he wants to he wants to completely
cut out
the environmental uh act that that
newsome has set forward here let me find
here it is newsome has a 4.1 billion
dollar environmental bill that
he yeah january 9th on 2020 and it's
it's really important for the
environment
and um you know like i said the sierra
club backs them all these
environmentalists back him and and you
know who else backs him
donna the boss yes yes and you know what
all of you you know i would never get
political but i'm just saying
you know it's the it's the uh
the industry he wants to deregulate uh
building codes so that people so the
builders can just go out and start you
know housing projects and that's going
to just totally rip apart the
habitat you know the butterflies are
hanging on by a string the animals that
live in this area the insects the
butterflies the bees you know
um
insects well you know i mean all these
guys you've lost me at insects well you
know there's there's all kinds of
creatures insects
yeah of course they are well we love
buttons
lepidoptera if i recall correctly okay
so we are we are pro-gavin yeah and and
the the the election is coming up in
september what is it the ninth fifteenth
that's the latest dude one of the
craziest things oh wait wait wait wait
what let me just tell you one more thing
whose show is this ethan
when if you're not registered to vote
get registered if you're registered to
vote you would have gotten cut off
i don't think so i think
i don't california so but can the person
with the actual political science degree
make a brief comment on this
on the the closeness
what was the youtube comment you made i
have a i have a ba in political science
from ucla or right
well is that a political genius one of
the most prestigious universities
um
the the closeness of the race is
uh based upon the fact that any time
there's uh a single issue like this the
people who are for the recall which are
basically republicans are super highly
motivated so polls show 85 percent 80
percent of republicans are going to vote
democrats are very complacent it's like
ah newsome's doing great what do we have
to worry about so only 45 percent or so
of democrats are excited to get out and
vote so
uh if that actually happens then
uh the replacement just needs to finish
first they don't even need more than 20
percent of the vote to become governor
for the next year so can't be complacent
and all you have to do is mail your
ballot back in everyone got ballots
mailed to them so
oh
larry
move back a little bit uh uh just fill
that ballot in he's watching mail it in
he's very very important okay can i say
something it's about butterflies but to
be honest this went off the rails a
little bit
like i wasn't actually trying to give
you guys a political soapbox
yeah you know what gary this whole thing
i wanted to avoid was saying democrat
republican because it's not a
or a butterfly issue
stop being so
political
it's a butterfly it's a butterfly
issue footage of of larry elder actually
pulling the wings off of butterbur so
there's that too that is okay all i have
to say is
you know
they're
they we have to protect these creatures
they can't they don't have a say
and and so many of these wonderful
little animals are in trouble and people
like he pulled a gun on his ex-wife he
did he pulled a gun on his as a matter
of fact that's pretty now that's a good
night let's talk about that i like last
week his fiancee accused him of verbal
and emotional emotional abuse it's right
there and he took a gun and he was
checking to see if if there was ammo in
it which was very intimidating to do
that to a person how'd you be willing to
do to a butterfly okay i don't think he
actually held the gun and pointed it at
him what does it say took out the gun
and brandished it and checked to see if
if it had uh if it was loaded so you
know that's a little intimidating you
can read the caption underneath there
you there's a cat you want someone to
read something yeah right below
me there we go larry elder's ex-fiancee
alleges a gun incident he denies it l.a
time so
do your own investigation all right save
the butterfly people this is off the
rails but one thing one thing i do want
to say it's really important when you
get your ballot
make sure that you you know you put in
the ballot into the envelope and if you
turn it around the part that you lick
and you seal you have to put your
signature on there don't turn it back
don't send it back without a signature
they'll just throw it away turn it over
it says it says and it says you
trust me it's hard to me thank you okay
well you know
sign the back you want to comment on
desantis or any other uh deep political
cuts i want to get into politics i only
care about you know
death scientists all right all right all
right i'm kidding let's go to a
commercial break when we come back we
got plenty more to do stay tuned it's
families the final episode yay
rocket this microphone is hitting the
market and i gotta say this thing is
slick and impressive and it's a
fantastic thing what is the rocket if
you've watched us maybe you've thought
hey i want to do that too maybe you want
to start a podcast
but you feel like you might have some
imposter syndrome well the torch mic
from rocket is here to make you and your
content sound fully legit with pro grade
sound quality i'll tell you from
personal experience the sound is so much
more important than the picture because
if the picture is grainy and crappy
looking uh you know you can kind of
infer what's going on but if the sound
is audio if the audio is bad you can't
listen it can't think audio needs to be
perfect
the torch mic is packed with pro
features including a dual condenser
design 24-bit audio quality and up to 40
48
hertz sampling that's audio nerd speak
for high quality sound
the torch also includes some really cool
features that are especially helpful for
streamers like a gesture activated mute
button how cool is that
so you can quickly mute your mic without
affecting the rest of your content bob
good night yeah hello that's smart the
torch mic also has mixer style controls
that allow gamers to adjust the settings
volume control and different pattern all
on the fly without installing any
drivers right here this is awesome yeah
you got all the settings right here
um
yeah we tried the mic out it sounds
fantastic i mean it's it's clean it's
impressed and what for like 100 bucks or
something i mean sir wow that's a great
price it's a steal yeah that sounds
pretty good so get yourself a torch mic
today and get professional quality sound
just click the link in the description
where uh we yeah so just go to the
description click the link
it's b-i-t it's point
it's one b-i-t
uh period l-y slash 3-g-q b-r-u-b
rubber baby just go to this link go to
description and click the link
thank you
[Laughter]
thank you to hello fresh you know hello
fresh they are the pre-measured
ingredients with mouth watering seasonal
recipes delivered right to your door you
get to skip the grocery store
uh home cooking is made easy fun and
affordable and that's why hello fresh is
number one america's number one meal kit
mom i think it's genius because you know
when you're busy working you come i'll
tell you what i'm going to make some
hello fresh tonight because
um i've got cameos to do
so i'm not cooking and you do not miss
an opportunity to plug your camo it's
impressive
oh no maybe i should take that test over
again
but i do like hello fresh i think it's
it's good hello fresh you know i agree i
love it it's really good we cook it all
the time and the thing is if you're too
busy
if you don't want to go to the grocery
store and get a bushel of celery when
you just need a little bit right it
gives you everything you need to make a
delicious uh you know home-cooked meal
uh
getting better value hello fresh is over
30 cheaper than shopping at the grocery
store because they've got pre-portioned
ingredients that ensures you won't spend
money on excess food then it ends up
going in the trash you know hellofresh
offers 50 menu and market items to
choose from every week from vegetarian
meals to calorie smart choices to extra
special gourmet options and there's
something for everyone to enjoy with
recipes designed and tested by
professional chefs and nutritional
experts to ensure deliciousness and
simplicity
so we've got a special offer too for our
uh audience if you go to hellofresh.com
families14
and use code families14 you're going to
get up to 14 free meals wow including
free shipping wow wow wow was right
that's hellofresh.com
families14 use code families14
for 14 up to 14 free meals wow and you
know
remember guys there's a reason it's
america's number one meal kit yay
if you're carrying around a credit
bounce month after month it can feel
like you're never in a never-ending
cycle of debt an upstart can help you
make that final payment so you can get
ahead upstart is the fast and easy way
to pay off your debt with a personal
loan all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses over
half a million people have used upstart
to get one fixed monthly payment upstart
knows you're more than just your credit
score and is expanding access to
affordable credit unlike other lenders
upstart considers your income current
employment define you a smarter rate for
your loan and with a five minute online
rate check you can see your rate up
front for loans between 1 000 to 50 000
and you can receive your funds as fast
as one business day after accepting your
loan so
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com h3 that's
upstart.com h3 don't forget to use our
url to let them know we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application remember that's upstart.com
h3
all right we are back and we are here to
gauge
how much of psychopaths basically
and i'm suspecting i think my mom's
pretty normal but my dad should be off
the charts i feel like i hope
[Laughter]
i mean just a guess
the dark triad we did this before with
uh dr young on the show and dr drew and
we did it with trisha and and everybody
and i think
basically a b and zack scored kind of
high
trisha was off the charts a b
scored hide i'm surprised i'm not really
okay if i recall he was only high in one
of the three categories but it was
really high in one of the things he was
he was high i forget now
he he's got a little
uh
he's a surrogate what can i say he's a
go-getter well you know that's a good
thing that's a good trait a little
narcissism is good
but then you look at so ian got the
lowest score they had ever seen
he got like a one
they're like he got like they're
celebrating like i'm gonna
be like that and i think i got a seven
which was like on the low side of you
know
dan did you take the test two i did uh
ethan and i's were about the same yeah
both of us were right in the middle
perfect
dr young said ethan and dan had the
perfect score no i'm just kidding
has a perfect score well this only
showed
zero to four though
at least the result you add them
cumulatively is the thing the way it was
worded though is would bob
so i don't think that they did an
official test because we just went to
some website yeah i mean we we actually
had people doctors
stepping us through it and explaining it
this was just a survey online it's a
little less official but go ahead dan
what what what uh what do we see uh i
actually i i put the results in your doc
if you want to pull that up for the
audience let's start with my mom here
hi i'm probably like a wimp or something
let's see
so according to this
it says that you need help urgently
[Laughter]
okay let's see the test is complete
i can't see
it says be prudent about sharing results
oops
oops
oh it's percentile well it's you got a
score and then the percentile is the
percentile of people that you are higher
than so you're pretty low on you're 11
you are you had a higher narcissism than
11 of people that take
the test so that means you're pretty low
right a little bit higher on the
machiavellianism
it's out of four so you have a two out
of four i see so she did so this might
be
yeah this is a low one
i think it means you are not you are a
noodle not a psychopath yeah not a cycle
okay well that's a good thing
so according to this it looks like you
got about a you know 4.2 or something so
so very good mom great thank you thank
you the butterflies are happy listen you
know i wish we had more insight you know
like when we did us but okay so here's
my dad
all right um
this is the one i'm curious about
we should talk about some of the way
that those questions were worded go
ahead what was some examples well i mean
oh stop it dad you lied on your test no
way
here's my dad's
which for some reason i can't even see
because it's so dark
apparently
dad
scored even lower than mom wow
sociopathy zero you lied no point four
it says you have a z
nobody personally dude dude
you that says no you are the least
sociopathic person in the world totally
believable well you know the [ __ ]
lied bro of people that have taken this
down zero
okay psychopathy even better
so you believe that
psychopathy thank you and and if anyone
is curious about uh machiavelli i i have
a degree in political science
i can't explain matthew valley to
everyone i think that's more of a
psychological donna had a higher
machiavellian rating than you i never
should have a degree so my dad scored
higher on narcissism but every but zero
i mean that's unbelievable
okay dude listen psycho psychopathy
reflects shallow emotional responses my
dad scored a zero what do you think
about that mom
clapping for myself
wait i got to go over these questions
i'm going to ask some of the questions
were asked wait put the test in here dan
i'm going to i'm going to quiz my dad
and get on honest answers out of him
well you know it's pretty easy to figure
out what the right answers are so you
did cheat no i bets no the right yeah
you've got a zero
i didn't compose the test i just took
the test
okay i'm gonna fact check you now all
right let's do this test together mom i
believe you're saying you're a saint
thank you
you're a butterfly saint thank you
you're leaving part of that out okay dad
let's do this test it is not wise to
tell your secrets
that's i would agree that people tell
you a secret they expect you to keep it
in place right people see me as a
natural leader
no that was neutral on that
no it's you don't think you if you were
on a jury jury if you had jury duty you
would definitely and if you had to be
part of the jury you don't think that
you would take the part of leader
definitely unless somebody was i have an
idea
okay so i think you agree let's be
honest i mean unless someone was certain
natural leader
i don't know you're a natural leader we
agree
i like to get revenge on authorities
no you won't buy certain products
because of your your ideas like like i
actually i was the same way so maybe
that i maybe i missed it i read i read
that differently but no what do you call
revenge no i disagree okay see that's
the thing it uses the word it we it uses
the word revenge i mean if you feel
strongly like we wouldn't buy tuna fish
for a while because they were throwing
nets over
yeah
that's that's like saying like let's say
you hate your body jessica did remember
what jessica did yes when she worked for
you go ahead tell what she did oh my god
i don't think he'll ever hear him still
hasn't made it to the public i think i
don't think well it was like a long [ __ ]
jessica i mean we all know we're talking
about our daughter don't say any names
of them
jessica
worked for gary at the bike shop for a
while and this person that used to be
there
she may she disliked him and she made a
sandwich and she put laxative in there
and he
had
a bad day yeah let's put that revenge on
it that is a revenge i would remember
never in a million okay so are you
trying revenge on authorities
yeah neutral or disagree let's do
neutral i like to use clever
manipulation to get my way
i was a so you middle agreed oh yeah i
was in a full agreement
give the answers oh my god yeah she's
gary you manipulate your daughters
is really good at manipulating okay good
so you guys are good at that this is
awesome and then you know what we should
do yo like this is so much better and
then dad you do mom's score okay and
then we can see the real results yeah
that's a good idea oh my god that can be
scary okay okay i hate being the center
of attention
disagree i i don't totally disagree dad
center of attention
whenever we get into a group yes you
like to you are dominating
again it depends on the circumstances
okay mom you answer you answer he loves
to dominate the conversation exactly
what do you mean
he enjoys it i mean you know he doesn't
want to like hey look at me but he does
he does enjoy it okay so then i avoid
dangerous situations
um i'd say absolutely because we're
going to agree
whatever it takes you must get the
important people on your side
i was i don't know i would say neutral
okay
many group activities tend to be dull
without me
neutral
yeah i'd say that's neutral ethan looks
disappointed
i i agree with neutral it's fine payback
needs to be quick and hasty
no i think dad's more calculated revenge
is a dish best served cold klingon say
that's my fault so you're saying you're
disagreeing
correct
avoid direct conflict with others
because they may be useful in the future
i don't disagree and that's just obvious
manipulating people so i was going to
disagree on that yeah i know that i'm
special because everyone keeps telling
me
no one tells me that so no disagree
people often say i'm out of control i
say that about you every day no i don't
no i'm not you're out of control you
know i don't disagree out of control
that means he's like
yeah yeah out of control is not like
that's what thinking sometimes the
teenager okay oh how far back are we
going yeah i was out of control then
weren't most teenagers
okay you're the one doing the rating i
wasn't rubbing putting dog [ __ ] on
people's doors
yeah
you blame sean for that yeah well maybe
you should be supervising us closer
um
you know when when you
read that read it again so people often
say i'm out of control you know i
wouldn't say he's out of control but
having said that
um remember i'm grading you next i know
i think sometimes
it's almost
let's say i agree
no it's not that he's out of control
he's never out of control you should say
sometimes i wish he would he would uh be
more in control he's too lackadaisical
okay so let's don't strongly definitely
control issue it's wise to keep track of
information that you can use against
people later
i would mildly agree with that i would
agree with that too interesting
yeah
well
i like to get acquainted with important
people that's a big agree on dad i think
dad likes to yeah that's a big idea
it's true that i can be mean to others
yes
i would agree yes is sarcasm being mean
oh my god i don't think of you as a mean
person but i find that interesting that
you guys both agreed on you know i think
sometimes
i think that you know activity on the
internet has made it easy to be mean to
people without it being consequential
not what i'm referring to
okay let's move on yeah you should wait
for the right time to get back at people
that seems like you're definitely you're
agreeing i agree
i feel embarrassed if someone
compliments me disagree big time
disagree yeah wait till mom gets that
one people who mess with me always
regret it answer people that mess with
me always regret it
no
i guess neutral
yeah you're really good at
sarcasm yeah
there are things you should hide from
other people because they don't need to
know
i think that that's you know i would
want that that's my dirty laundry
[Music]
i'm just trying to skew this the most
psychotic i can't make it would expect
nothing less i've been compared to
famous people agree
well yeah stephen stephen king
and colonel sanders that is i mean you
know basically see that's
i've never gotten into trouble with the
law that is true that's true out of pure
luck of course for my younger days but
um so make plans to benefit you not
others
disagree
okay
i am an average person
disagree you're not an average person i
enjoy having sex with people i hardly
know i mean wow
younger days okay i agree just be honest
in my younger yeah yeah i most people
can be manipulated
i say a lot of people can be men not you
or dad
i i would i know
you asked me
yeah between neutral and agree okay
we're doing agree i insist on getting
the respect i deserve what i'm saying
there right or if you're keeping score
i'm keeping score oh you're keeping i
insist on getting the respect i deserve
i don't know if he insists on it
but i'm gumby damn it give me respect
i'm gonna say i agree
neutral yeah neutral i'll say anything
to get what i want
disagree all right let's see now here's
the real test i thought i was supposed
to do this you're next okay now i mean
like now we're talking your answer
here's the real results
see he manipulates he answered the
questions and said totally now here's
the real results
yeah real reason uh-oh it is
the maki of narcissism seventy percent
we've got bundled up
no what you put down is miami everything
we said i didn't cheat we had
disagreements on some of those but
whatever well it's still very low on uh
uh so uh
psychopathy which would be good yeah but
machiavellianism and narcissism you're
pretty high
but not terribly high
yeah i think this is accurate
no jessica and i have discussed the
narcissism and selfishness uh gene that
comes from my side of the face
but we are constantly fighting it as we
become so there you go so you agree this
is more accurate
this is good
but now let's get to mom
oh
there's some problems with this test
okay so dad
this is your turn okay just to show you
in my previous statement about
uh revenge is a dish best served cult
this quickly so it's revenge time all
right it's not yeah i don't think i was
mean oh yeah straight up i'm i'm kidding
kind of well
we think we want light on you
because we said you don't seek out
dangerous acts but like half of
everything i've talked about you is
either trying to kill me in the car or
stabbing beach balls or getting in
fights at star wars premieres right but
it's it's the test taker's perception of
danger right now and growing up i was
always kind of the chicken of the group
people were doing dangerous things and i
was just like yeah no i don't think but
that doesn't seek out dangerous no i
mean the star wars people that those
those guys
assaulted us we had nothing to do all
right you ready it's not wise to tell
your secrets
i think mom wouldn't i think of it
yeah yeah i don't think it's a good idea
yeah exactly someone tells me a secret
mom's the worst mom yeah
people see me as a natural leader well
the don arks and the butterflies would
all agree with that of course but i i
don't think i see myself i would just
okay neutral i think i was neutral i
think i put i like to get revenge on
authorities no she's not a revengey type
person yeah i like to use clever
manipulations to get my way
no i'm not manipulative at all i wish i
was yeah neutral i really wish i was i
hate being the center of attention
disagree
you think you like you think i like
being the center of attention i think so
i like i would go i get embarrassed i
think dad's right too the middle column
you know not the whole maybe here agree
but okay okay yeah i avoid dangerous
decisions that's for sure yeah
of course she married me
little did i know whatever it takes you
must get the important people on your
side
disagree yeah i don't i don't many group
activities tend to be dull without me no
yeah that's easy disagree payback needs
to be quick and hasty i don't really do
anything you disagree
yeah quick and nasty cooking i don't i
don't pay back i agree
avoid direct conflict with others
because they may be useful in the future
yeah
damn mom really does not exist on this
this is not a great very nuanced test
though let's be honest it's not at all
because like the score high you
basically have to be like i am a
psychologist exactly that might as well
be one of the questions are you a
psychotic
i know that i'm special because everyone
keeps telling me so no
disagree
people often say i'm out of control
definitely i'm so out of control
it's wise to keep track of information
you can use against people later that's
a definitely not right
yeah yeah
i like to get acquainted with important
people i don't think she cares about it
about going to
you know dinner with with the edge and
that group of people i think i was just
interested in that
going
no i was kind of
i was kind of embarrassed i mean i was
like why are you inviting me i felt like
i was intruding actually to be honest
about that it's your choice
i mean i was i was i thought it was nice
that you guys included me but i felt
like i i didn't want to intrude it's
true that i can be mean to others that's
true you can be a little mean at times
to your husband
ah
that is your choice
i go the the next to agree yeah that one
oh my god you should wait for the right
time to get back at people
mom's not really a vengeful person i i
would go neutral i feel embarrassed that
someone compliments me
wait so you answered gave the wrong
answer there
you wait for the right time was that
negative i should wait for the right
time to i don't
i do feel embarrassed when you're
complimented she definitely does she
cannot take a compliment no matter how
sincere or honest it is people who mess
with me always regret it
disagree
there are things you should hide from
other people because they don't need to
know
that's a true i think that's basically
true yes i agree
i've been compared to famous people some
yeah some people thought i look like
cher okay so i you know i've never
gotten into trouble with the law that's
okay let's agree yes
make sure your plans benefit you not
others no mom's not selfish at all
disagree
i'm an average person she's way above
average disagree
wait i mean i see that oh okay i see
that as being pejorative but that's just
my opinion it is i'm an average person
i enjoy having sex with people i hardly
know she's definitely agree on that
most uh you're kidding right i'm kidding
yeah okay
not that i know of
most people can be manipulated you say i
answer that i think i think there's a
lot of people think not that i would do
it yeah but i think
i mean look at all the people that
you know they they take they take things
on the internet and they believe it yeah
like they don't investigate so they're
being manipulated right do you insist on
getting the respect you deserve
neutral i don't think i insist on
anything if i say any i'll say anything
to get what i want
disagree who's gonna admit to that no i
don't i wouldn't all right mom is
probably her score probably didn't
change that much probably not yeah let's
see
oh it's a lot higher than it was was it
what was it before or was it is it not
yeah
it was about liar
it's you're 17 on narcissism
11 machiavellian and zero you got that
coveted zero
she actually dropped psychopathy the
original uh percentiles for her were 11
20 and 1. how did we go down to
machiavellian i don't know you guys
answered so dad you know what's actually
really sweet dad gave you the score
and you got a better score with dad
picking you're welcome you can thank me
yeah so dad is a psychopath as we all
knew oh no not a psychopath a narcissist
yeah and a machiavellian
just because of my poli-sci degree right
of course you are you are orientated
yeah
okay there you go pretty interesting
well what is that fascinating yes
fascinating
what does that say
it sounds like it says it's a different
test yeah i'm just going to say
it sounds like a dumb test
all right you want to do some advice and
then we'll do a little bit of a
retrospective we put together okay a
little bit of an edit for us to enjoy
okay that sounds like fun all right
here we go here we go so this is the
remember this is the dumping button oh
so if you ever think i should just dump
him you just hit that i will and
remember wait what was the word
no wait no grass touch the grass
no it wasn't smoke congrats you're
making that up he's not making that
touch the grass
touch thing poke the grass touch the
grass
it's you need to touch grass we need to
touch grass touch grass
what is it touch grass okay what is it
oh stop all right here we go my
nine-year-old
is on tick tock hello ethan and donna i
get this one you don't really know that
much about tick tock so i'll take the
lead on this one well i okay go ahead
um i feel you guys would have some
realistic advice for me i'm a single mom
of a nine-year-old girl who's constantly
asking to be on tick-tock i don't like
this idea for three reasons one there
are predators who will watch your videos
and do uh and do who knows what
and do who knows what with those videos
two there's a lot of adult themed videos
and three there are children her age who
are not being monitored by their parents
and watching commenting inappropriate
things
a lot of my videos on tick tock have
comments from kids my daughter's age
asks me to take my shirt off and work
makes me uncomfortable but there's no
way to filter this app to keep the kids
off what would you guys recommend
should i stick to my guns on tick tock
because i know what people what the
videos are like or should i just let her
on the app and have her see it because
someday she will anyway that's a tough
one aren't there regulations of some
kind
like it for for miners well obscenity no
there's no minor regulation well i think
there's obscenity they don't allow
no you can abuse you can curse i think i
think their their terms of service is
probably like 14 or something maybe you
can look into that dan but obviously
that doesn't prevent anyone from going
on tick tock
you know if you're under i wrote down
here i you know i um
well i meant no nudity they don't allow
no on the site no but there's pretty
risque stuff on there i
i think there's some sort of restriction
if you're under the age of 13 that you
can't post or you can't do something
i think i'd stick to your guys i think
she wants oh so if you're but how do you
prove that you're 13 how does that even
work i mean just like i think you don't
just like anything yeah but by the
letter oh sorry you can just lie and say
i'm people lie and they just lie on
these somebody
oh wow
can you believe people just go on the
internet and lie oh i think you do
really hard to regulate i thought maybe
there was some kind of parental digital
button that you think sure or something
there's not so honestly wow tough one
because i spent a lot of time on tick
tock and there's some wild [ __ ] on that
app i'll tell you what man there is some
really
inappropriate stuff there
stuff your guns i say there's there's
one comment that's always funny whenever
i see a video that really like is like
wow i can't believe this is on the app
they always comment people are way too
comfortable on this app
and there's a lot of that
so everybody in there and susie's on
that
because
yeah i was thinking it's an expression i
i wasn't susie i i have no idea just an
expression everyone in your aunt susie
how do you know aunt susie's on the app
because everybody's on the app so aunt
susie must be honest
you know i i um became metaphorically
yeah metaphorically exactly
i was thinking of getting onto tick-tock
but i like
i don't know that it's just like it's
crazy it's like the wild west well you
have that wonderful dance video up on
tick tock all right yeah right that's
true so you know you should get on tick
tock and you should you should post
butterfly content and tick tock i
guarantee you you will have yeah you
think so oh yeah yeah oh yeah well i'll
help you set it up and we'll promote it
on the show when we really well i would
do that if i could do things that are
you would blow up on
those tick tock pages probably even
butterfly talk like people joke about
how their genres for everything they
call it really there's even like a
tourettes talk really
yeah that trisha kept always talking
about it's like but i've never i've
never been on that side of tick tock but
i bet you there's a butterfly talk oh
wow okay you could start it and just
does tick-tock pay
a little bit yeah not like well i would
it would just be you know like that
would be it's not as simple to do 50
bucks a view is that uh yeah something
like that
so anyway let's let's so
here's the problem right she's a
nine-year-old girl the pro this is a
really tough situation these this girl's
gonna go on tick tock she's gonna be at
school i don't know if she pro has a
phone or what but her friends have
phones they're all gonna be on tick tock
so
prohibiting her is not going to totally
cut her off tick-tock right but it will
substantially reduce her exposure to the
app
so you know there's lots of things to
weigh here it's like she's still going
to be exposed to the app via her
friend's phones
but if you're asking should she post
videos to tick-tock no
no that could be scary it's gonna get
creepy and weird i guarantee you the
only people that are gonna engage with
her content are
creepy freaks and that happened on
youtube that's the case in point there
was there was like kids posting videos
to youtube and this was a big
controversy recently where youtube
turned off all comments for kids content
because like dude there was
stuff was so disturbing like there'd be
like an innocent nine-year-old girl just
playing in a room and then these cr dude
i'm telling you it's so disturbing they
would go in the comments and time stamp
where you could like see her underwear
what
yeah wow
yeah
it was a huge scandal and it was just so
disturbing
people were making like playlists
oh my gosh
it was like
it was a big deal on youtube where they
finally addressed this issue they turned
off comments on all kids good stuff and
um
they cleaned it up a lot so what i'm
expecting is if your nine-year-old
daughter is posting videos on tick tock
it's going to be not it's going to be
unsavory just to put it mildly so i for
i first of all would not allow her
to post until she was 13. but how do you
stop them like you said if they're at
school well
well she's gonna you just need to step
she's gonna be exposed to tick-tock but
she's probably not gonna be able to post
stuff if she's just at school right well
if she's under 13 right you can't post
but what happens if she's like they
can't post you know what i mean right i
don't know i don't know how you would
control them look you're gonna have to
accept you can't control everything in
her life is she gonna use her friend's
phone to make an account and post you
can't control it but what you can
control is what happens in your house
and the less exposure the better and i
think probably what you should do is try
to have an honest conversation with her
i mean she's nine years old she's pretty
she's probably a smart girl she
understands a lot of the world
just say listen
on tick tock if you post videos there
before you're old enough you're going to
attract
disgusting people scary
it's going to be it's going to be
disgusting and this is going to be
really gross attention that you're not
going to want to have imagine you're
walking around a mall and some old guy
comes and starts hitting on you
like i mean that's that's it's it's
horrifying right that's what's going to
happen on tick tock oh a nine-year-old
little girl so you don't
just say you know it's not it's just not
safe for you yeah there's a reason we
set age limits for things like she's not
old enough to drink i mean this is one
of those things that you need a level of
maturity to protect yourself
before you participate in it and i think
you know at that young age
you know you just don't have a concept
of the big picture as you were saying
right of what potential downside of
doing that they're so innocent they
don't think about that they just think
oh this is this is the social media
platform and it's a problem because they
probably have a lot of friends that are
on tick tock they want to dance and sing
and show off and and they don't realize
there's a lot of people watching
i think i think what would be smart is
if
when she's 13 let's say and you say okay
you know you can have an account now
it's different if she's just browsing
maybe say you can browse but do not post
anything until you're older and when she
does make you can you can follow her on
tick tock and see what she's doing you
can read the comments and
you know just see if anything's going
sideways there oh yeah i would keep my
eye on but
you have to accept this uh painful truth
is that you can't control what they're
doing and they're gonna get into it
regardless so my my theory on that is
don't you can't prohibit you can't
control
you've got to accept that all you can do
is
guide give advice and help them in an
honest open loving way
because at the end of the day that's all
you can do right so you've got to give
them the best advice it's not going to
make them hate you too because if you
just hey
you can't use tick tock i'm not
explaining why you can't use it i'm
taking your phone then they're just
going to hate you they're going to
resent you they're going to go on it
anyway right and they're not going to
know the dangers that they're facing i
think you should tell your daughter at 9
years old that you should go out and
touch the grass oh yeah well that was
good
that was a perfect usage
nicely done
nicely done
so that's it you know i i it's a tough
situation to be in but yeah take always
take the stance of supporting through
communication via banning and uh control
yep
thank you thank you peace boy you know i
wouldn't want to be a parent
at this stage stage tricky it's really
tricky i thought we had it rough
there was no pandemic when we oh my god
either yeah
when to tell my partner i used to be a
stripper
i donna gary and ethan
i was wondering if you guys had any
advice i want to tell someone i'm dating
that i used to be a stripper it's not
something i mentioned right away because
a big concern of mine is safety
i told someone once and when things
ended they found out and contacted my
family and tried to blackmail me jesus
wow i only did it for a couple of months
two years ago and it was a really clean
club no funny business
is it something even worth mentioning
i know it would be a deal breaker for
some people any advice on how to deal
with this part of my past
thank you
you know if she was a stripper
and um
she said she was doing it just for
to put her wait what did she say she
said she did it for a few months right
just for a few months like you know
i think
when you start dating someone
you know you're kind of feeling each
other out learning about
each other's uh likes dislikes i don't
think you should disclose
certain things at the beginning until
you feel so comfortable that you know
you kind of have an idea of who this
person
is because you don't really want to
um
share that i don't think because of what
from what she said before
when she was dating someone and he used
it against her
that seems unusual though that's pretty
psycho
yes i know i mean if i was dating
someone i think i would want to be
honest from the start to say this is who
i am you know if you like me fine if not
let's not even go there but but i don't
know with the stripper
it might uh freak somebody out maybe
once they get to know you they realize
that you're really a good person and the
mere fact that you did this
they can overlook it but it might put
like a wall up immediately if you tell
them right away
as someone who's never been in a strip
club
i can speak to this a little bit
you know i i think obviously you're a
fairly open-minded person
and you need to have a relationship with
someone
with similar thoughts similar ideas so
you know i would say telling someone
right away
isn't good but after you've been in a
relationship for a while and you know
the person well
um
it shouldn't be a big deal to explain to
someone that you have a good open
relationship with that you know would be
accepting of something like that or at
least not storm out um you know
it would be okay
at that point i think
what is i i don't see any problem with
this girl being a stripper i mean i
don't think that this is something to
even necessarily be that ashamed of i
mean
stripping like if you were like a
prostitute not that i think there's
anything wrong with that either that's a
little harder to that's like a bigger
hurdle kind of to talk about just
because you know
for obvious reasons being a stripper i
don't think that's something that you
even need to be ashamed of or
embarrassed about i mean i mean it
depends on what your profession is too i
mean if you do stripping and then later
on you want to go into politics maybe
that's a good thing to do obviously i
don't think she's worried about going
into politics yeah but like i i honestly
just like if i was with a girl that i
really liked and for all the right
reasons and she's like i used to strip
for a few months i'd be i would be i
would be amused i mean what do i care if
she's stripped i mean you you know what
if you were like on your first date and
she shared that with you
i honestly would that bother you i don't
think it would bother me it wouldn't you
wouldn't think twice about dude do i
really want to date this girl or not no
it would bother some guys i think that
guy you probably wouldn't want it anyway
if she was actively stripping then it
might again it's just it's different
it's a whole different that's a whole
different conversation but if you're
like i used to strip for a few months
and you know i'd be like well the only
you know the only the only problem we
don't see it as being a big deal
well maybe she's from a conservative
family where they explore they say if
people are trying to blackmail say like
oh you're a stripper i'm telling
everyone you know then i i don't know
maybe she's in a part of the world where
part of the country where you know she's
in saudi arabia
but
also you're dating the wrong guys bro i
don't know how you get hooked up with a
guy who is willing to blackmail you like
that i mean that is literally psychic
see that's the thing if when you first
start dating someone and you really
don't you really don't know who this
person is
that's the thing you know you you might
think you know someone you see someone
you think you're attracted to him he was
funny or whatever and you go out on a
couple of dates and you go you know what
you're not who i thought yeah you were
right and so that's what i'm saying it's
better like what dad said it's better to
wait
to kind of get a feel of who this person
is do you even care to share your
secrets with this person wait see where
he's at and then if you're serious and
you really think maybe i could like this
guy yeah then i would be but don't be
embarrassed look don't let don't give
them that power of it you're a stripper
just [ __ ] own it you you're out there
you know making a living dude times are
hard you got to do what you got to do i
just think she needs to protect herself
and not
give herself away at the very beginning
until she feels comfortable she knows
this person but also i think of your
friends and families and people who like
i mean
i just think
it's it's nothing to be embarrassed
about honestly you should just be proud
of who you are you moved on to different
things for whatever reason and
obviously i don't think you need to be
ashamed of it
so right go for it right live your life
yeah i agree with that
that wasn't so hard
weird relationship rules
i've been with my boyfriend for about
two years now i'm a full-time student
and my boyfriend is not currently in
school
at the end of the day i look forward to
talking to him but he's almost never
willing to talk with me after a long day
we have a relationship rule created by
him that we may not see each other more
than one time a week at times it will be
well over a month since i've seen him in
person and sometimes days before i've
even spoken to him on the phone
can i address that i'm not well i'm
still ready oh sorry sometimes days
before
that was enough he says he is busy but i
have his location enabled and he is 99
of the time at home donna please tell me
what to do
yeah i'm with you there that dude is
weird weird weird
no comment necessary no comment even
necessary
this is the guy when you if you date him
and he moves in he'll lock himself in
the bedroom right like that
they're going to turn into that guy
right look what i'll say about this guys
he's
clearly
got issues he might be a great guy he
might be all the best things but like
this guy has demons there's something
torturing this man and if he's not in
therapy if he's not being treated i mean
god bless him we're all like born
innocent and and become what we are as a
result of things that happen to us our
alive so it's hard to blame people for
whatever damage happens to them and
cause them the way they be but you got
to live your life
that makes you happy you deserve to be
with someone that actually [ __ ] wants
to spend time with you every day yeah
yeah i mean maybe he's dating multiple
amounts of women and so that's why he's
limiting
her access to their relationship well
whatever it is maybe he just has
anxieties and he's depressed and
whatever problems he's at home ninety
percent of the time but if the dude
isn't he needs to work on himself he's
not ready to be in a relationship yeah i
mean you want someone as close to normal
as possible and that i think he's a
player
that's the same normal but somebody
who's actually ready to be in a
relationship who wants to be with you
who's willing to spend time with you and
give you what you need i think
normal you want to be with each other
when dad and i were dating from the from
the first day we went out i mean we were
inseparable we were glued to the hip we
went everywhere together
and other places also oh gary
yeah i don't even know why you're
putting up with this like i again a lot
of these we don't have enough details
but it's like you guys have been dating
for a while it sounds like and you say
you go times where you don't even see
him for a month i mean what kind of
relationship
i'm telling you he's a player you are
worth more dating other women this man
bringing her along
i just i i i don't know why people even
i don't know man but
yeah you gotta do better than that for
yourself yeah
and don't try to fix him he's not your
burden to bear he's not your cross to
bear
he needs to fix himself and then go out
and meet people you know what i mean
some people are just savers
you don't want to be one you don't want
to be a saver no you can be a saver to
an extent like it's a nice quality to
have but some people some people get
really they take it too far and you just
you end up ruining your own life just to
save people that are just not ready yep
to be saved
i agree
all right an easy one too
boyfriend won't brush his teeth
yeah you don't need to know anymore
you hitting this are you waiting
why would you not want to brush your
teeth well your teeth are going to fall
out of your hair okay i've been dating
my boyfriend for over two years now and
he doesn't brush his teeth at night only
in the morning
okay he's gonna have gumdrops overall a
very clean person so this isn't
something that you would necessarily
expect from him he says he stopped a
long time ago because his breath still
smells in the morning so what is even
the point dude i i my first girlfriend
in high school
she said the same exact thing really she
doesn't brush her teeth at night only
the morning because what's the point and
i thought that was really weird at the
time she didn't have stinky breath but
maybe she doesn't know
she was you know i mean all the things
that you you eat you put in your mouth
all that decay and bacteria you got to
clean it out or you're going to have
cavities up the yin yang she continues
um
we all know there's more brushing your
teeth than the smell of your breath he
knows that brushing his teeth twice a
day is the right thing to do but he yet
pleads bad habits laziness stubbornness
as to why he won't start now
even after all
he went through did he go through stuff
i am really struggling with his logic
here and have had enough trying to argue
over such silly topic then we both know
i'm 100 right what do i do
that's pretty funny
dump him
well you know if she really likes him
she needs to explain are we really at
the point where we're dumping people
because they only brush one time no no
no you you can't you know if you don't
ring the bell we'll unring them yeah
yeah
dad you want to hit it there's a logical
disconnect here though dude he brushes
one time a day you ready to dump him for
that no you just gotta you know
share let's look down the road okay we
have a great relationship two years oh
baby i love you let's get married okay
you get married you have kids the kids
are four or five okay go brush your
teeth daddy doesn't brush his teeth why
should i brush my teeth you can see all
kinds of horrible things coming from
that just how many more horrible things
can you see coming from that other than
that one situation you described
many right
okay doctor of uh
va of bachelor of science psychopathy
also
you know
you don't want to be somebody's mother
i hate being put in a situation like
that but if i had a boyfriend
that i really cared about and he didn't
brush his teeth in the evening
i of course would explain
how i felt about
him brushing his teeth and why he should
i mean if they refuse to brush their
teeth no matter what i say did she just
did you ever say anything to that girl
like you should brush your teeth we were
young we were like 15.
we were i just thought it was really
weird i never heard that i don't know i
don't i don't know how i would handle
that maybe maybe that would be something
that would turn me off so much i'm so
about dental hygiene
you know i i've always tried to instill
that upon you kids that your teeth with
oral hygiene you know i mean your teeth
have got to last you the rest of your
life what are you doing okay here's what
maybe you need to explain to him
when you don't brush your teeth at night
that's when you get that's when you
cause the most damage to your gums
and your disease and because when you
sit there at night in your bed and your
mouth is closed you're not eating or
drinking saliva cleans your mouth and so
when you chew and you're eating
throughout the day keeps your mouth
healthy but when you're sitting in bed
you know for eight hours where your
mouth is closed that's when the bacteria
breeds and causes the most damage so
when you don't brush before bed that's
actually the most damaging thing that
you can do for your mouth that's the
most important time to brush
i know that brushing in the morning you
know you wake up with bad breath and all
that you know but
that's what you've got that's it
so her her theory my my girlfriend from
high school was like what's the point i
wake up with stinky breath after brush
anyway the point is that bacteria is
going to wreak havoc on your mouth at
night and you need to
brush before bed to prevent that from
happening
decay can go right to your brain yeah
the point of brushing your teeth heart
disease there's so many things isn't
just to sweeten your breath it's to keep
from getting cavities and maintain good
oral hygiene right right but but to the
point of what do you do i mean
what can you do i mean listen
i mean people are you know we all deal
with weird things with our spouses i
don't know what to tell you i mean the
guy's not going to brush his teeth i
don't know what to tell you you're just
going to you're going to be married to a
dude that brushes his teeth once a day i
mean i i think you just got to deal with
it but if you can't convince him to do
that what other strange things yeah no
bad won't you be able to convince him to
do even though it's the right thing to
do i see you're you're you're saying he
has a disconnect here what else does he
have this right well that's true that's
a good point gary okay but let's be
honest we're not dumb we're not
advocating dumping because the man
brushes once a day right she just has to
evaluate the situation and say to
herself how much do i really it's not
that big of a guy
try to get him to brush at night what
can i say it's not that big of a deal
right hand him all the info of all the
things you could deal with that we've
heard of here on this show right not
brushing your teeth come on and then you
can help him change his dentures when
he's older and
all these teeth if he won't brush at
least try to get him to like use
mouthwash or something at night like try
to do something
like look dude this is gross i know you
don't want to brush maybe you're too
lazy just rinse some mouthwash that's
easy i know what you can do
if you seduce him and you want to be
romantic
say you got to brush your teeth if
you're coming to bed with me because i'm
not going to kiss you so use sex as
leverage
maybe
interesting very machiavellian right
yeah oh
i didn't realize i had it in a very
psychopath psychotic
that's not psycho maybe if he's a real
heavy sleeper you could brush his teeth
while he's sleeping yeah oh then he
would choke
you know also gum is really good for the
oral hygiene and the and you can get him
to choose some gum sugar that's pathetic
though just just be like dude
easy
quick and easy yeah love those bristles
yeah i don't know what to tell you man
you you're you're you're in a
relationship with them with an animal
don't even try don't even try to get
them started on flossing
kiss kiss a guy whose mouth
smells like your dogs
the one the number one instant turn off
for me no matter what if she is like a
perfect 10 like damn perfect girl even
person i'll say she's a per i'll do it
i'll even go shallow saying she has a
perfect personality she's amazing and
she's super into me if she's got bad
breath i'm like sorry i can't do this i
can't do it
see i can even see past that and help
the breath i'm like a teeth
like you have to have good teeth like
look at your mother i mean she has the
greatest teeth that was one of the
things that attract her and if you don't
brush your teeth you're not going to
have perfect teeth
some people have really good teeth
despite their lack of yeah you know what
let me walk some people have bad breath
it's a medical condition so yeah no hate
and just hear them i would i would not
reject you in that case if it was an
oral hygiene then i'm saying bye bye
yeah yeah dump him
oh we're back to that
move out in the middle of the night
never talk to him again oh
god
can you pull up bye-bye by the
backstreet boys dan in the meantime i
don't i don't think we're going to have
a license to them
well that brings us about to the end
here oh
yeah i'm going to miss you guys
we have a special little video oh cool
that will watch okay
so here it is okay
it's very exciting to introduce our new
co-host
my
mom
thank you thank you thank you
has ethan ever smoked crack i don't
think so wrong
i don't think we ever smoked anything
like that did we speak for yourself oh
we're learning all kinds of stuff you
know when you're a kid and you start
rummaging through your parents stuff i
found in my mom's side
the biggest [ __ ] dildo it's like
a moment
that is forever burned in my brain send
email to
dan no you seem to have somehow acted oh
that was so pathetic oh my god
i'm not sure how you did that
so we have a family's advice segment
here today oh ditch the guy she's dating
the wrong guy i'd say dump his ass all
right
you would be dad's shouting eat
eat team skeet all gary falls these
crazy porn accounts three
porn stars but the reports that i've had
range between 112 and
134 accounts wow
i was never good at counting yeah oh my
god that was embarrassing for you
actually i'm a brilliant political
thinker with the ba oh this is it this
is the quote there it is actually i'm a
brilliant political thinker with a ba in
political science from ucla sorry to
disappoint you
obviously they're sarcasm there was it
about brilliant political thinker just
for some random okay
from ucla sorry to disappoint you went
to dodger stadium people would throw the
beach balls around you would grab them
and stab them with a
knife oh that was so funny
i left so hard tears were coming down my
face
i'm trying to find you a friend where
are you from oh my god
she's in love but i'm out there's
somebody's yeah
i can't believe you put me through that
that's the grain ah oh that's how you
know
so that is a grand total she could have
should have cut in that guy's neck with
the lacerations all over it
157 points
dad and i were watching that game the
other night and we didn't play it right
yes we did no uh-uh what did we do wrong
we weren't supposed to um share the
answers with our fellow contestants but
they're always cheating
no
richard dawson just goes up to
individuals
yes
[Laughter]
going on about butterflies she says
listen i'm she's ready to do a spin-off
show
the monarch butterfly is in so much
trouble because of the mexican cartel i
just think it's a it's a wake-up call
for everyone
[Music]
i think you've earned your wings yay
[Applause]
you see the blanket i made that for you
good you brought that around you
everywhere you went he's like damn i
don't know how i got away with this one
i'm still saying that scroll down
look at that
that's ethan i raised such a good boy
you email me i'm gonna get buy you a
thousand dollar gift card to american
eagle oh wow
he's just born with uh incredible
strength and you're born with incredible
beauty that's very sweet
you're welcome mom rekindled the
father-son bond definitely
thank you for watching families
ciao smash that like button thanks
everybody
wow
it really was
it was a beautiful journey we covered a
lot we did it all we said it all
it was fun it was a lot of fun it was
fun to share the experience with you
guys it was a special
i sure learned a lot i sure learned a
lot i had no idea what what was out
there in this whole yeah you guys are on
the social media world i know you've
created a monster eat this that's why
i'm ending the show
just kidding no i love it i just
absolutely i'm gonna have ethan teach me
how to get on tick tock yeah she's gonna
make a butterfly tick tock account i'll
let you guys know when we uh launch that
that'll be fun yeah that'll be a lot of
fun
well mom
can i take the butterflies with me
yeah we have a bunch of them it's just
little oh we have to return those
actually i love you
a butterfly queen not only me the whole
everybody loves you quick throw another
touch the grass in
i said
no one one one per episode
i would just like to say that um
your staff
is really great yeah you're a very lucky
guy
you're a very lucky guy they're the best
in the game dan's the only one here
today but every everybody yeah
especially dan they are the best you
guys are great you really are
dad any parting words uh for the people
it's been a lot more fun than i had
anticipated really i didn't
you know want to participate much at all
at the beginning but then
i was in the background wisecracking and
then got on camera and it's been
been a lot of fun been fulfilling uh
uh i'm on cameo 2 plug plug
and not nearly getting the traffic that
your mother is and that is
certainly justifiable
but your fans are fantastic whether it's
communicating online or whether it's
uh them coming up to us on purpose
that's one thing mom doesn't like about
new mask mandate she's recognized much
less now with covering your face
although someone really eyes or even
with the mask on i will say my mom loves
when people come say hi she
can take pictures so i can show it on
the show i know
everybody they're so sweet when they
come up to me and and and uh introduce
themselves and tell tell me how much
they love your show
i love it i love it yeah the fans are
great thanks for your support of
families
and uh if you disagree with ethan's
decision
flood that inbox
that's not what i need so
and it's not it's not goodbye forever
right we're gonna do some fun things
here they're gonna be having a recurring
segment on the show it'll be fine the
butterfly queen my parents are not going
anywhere yes
we're family
you're stuck with us
off the show emotional and i will say
i've had a lot of fun i feel like we
bonded
the people love you guys i've learned a
lot about butterflies
well that's good
you know and don't forget to vote the
most shocking thing i learned i think
from all of this
is that the cartel sell avocado
yeah that still blows my mind yeah
yeah that's uh it's an indirect issue
indirectly
directly the new green crop yeah no
longer marijuana it's all vocabulary
it's avocados
there you go
indirectly and they don't plant them
they just no no no don't intimidate the
ground i like the idea that they plant
them all right they do plant agriculture
now oh see mom says they do
you know how long it takes to get
avocados from well they well they they
they steal the land
they just become legitimate farmers
they're never they're well they're not
legitimate because they take the land
from from these little farmers
so
cartel free avocados guys yeah
yep
look for that made in the usa sticker on
there
okay
all right well everybody
oh so i should talk about the schedule
you know where our schedule is normal
this week but starting next week because
families is ending we're going to be
doing we we're unveiling soon a new
co-host a new show oh i'm very excited
i'm still working out the details but um
i'm super excited about what's coming up
and
um we're also gonna be doing h3 tv every
monday now which is going to be live on
youtube no longer on twitch we're going
to be here for the people we're going to
be taking call-ins every monday taking
suggestions we've got four s
we've got four call screeners set up for
that live experience every monday h3 tv
is going to be nice
that'll be good like one we'll figure it
out the exact somewhere around that and
then on tuesday
we are hoping to slot the new show
there can we get this very exciting
co-host is going to be it might be a
surprise i prefer not to guess yeah all
right yeah
it would have been a bad guess and you
want to give me a guess a bad guess
gabby hannah
that's a bad guess huh we got it we got
that is a bad guess oh
keemstar would have even been worse yeah
keemstar there we go that's a bad guess
yeah even worse guess so exciting things
to come
well i wish you the best of luck
you better yeah
and and i think it's gonna be great i
think it's nice to switch out co-hosts
it's it's it gives everything a new
fresh
you know feel to it
continued growth of the h3 and petty
fresh empire i'm very proud of my son
and you know we only had the new curtain
for one day but our one episode but uh
we got two episodes out of it we got two
well today we got two ups out of that so
well you can use that
you can use it again
probably not probably not uh maybe maybe
we could do reoccurring like emergency
family a family reunion yeah family
reunion it's even got a perfect name
already yeah we can do it nice okay yeah
like in two weeks well
like next week yeah you know if we do a
week and every week
yeah right we could do a like a phone in
when you called me on the car
yeah that's what i want to do yeah as
long as i oh my god that was crazy
my thought is
that when there's like a big drama
happening we can call you guys and get
you to weigh in oh that would be fine
donna the drama investigator
that i'll have my notes ready
we know that you will
ah
all right guys
everyone love you guys love you signing
out
bye
smash the like button for the last time
this month
[Music]